le port de bordeaux accueillera cette
année 15 paquebot de croisière 5 287 ce
qui fonctionne au gain l'expansion
fulgurante de cette activité touristique
aujourd'hui point navires font escale à
bordeaux le biélorusse ya soviétique se
rende au caire qu'à marseille qui à
l'espagne et le portugal
il embarquera bordeaux 175 passagers le
net une qui bat pavillon grec transport
207 passagers américains le long des
côtes françaises
enfin le royal liqing style norvégien
arrivera cette nuit avec 600 passagers
américaine il vient du danemark et vont
au portugal via l'angleterre bordeaux et
l'espagne
l'escale de bordeaux pour ce qui nous
concerne nous permet de faire monter à
bord des passagers du sud et notamment
du sud-ouest de la france donc et leur
éviter ainsi de monter chercher le
navirad un pierre cros havre à c'est une
escale un petit peu technique mais ceci
étant bordeaux et si tu es donc dans une
partie médiane qui au niveau du
développement de la croisière va
permettre je pense à
d'autres navires de s'arrêter de façon à
faire une jonction entre les maires du
nord
et puis les mers du sud qui sont soit la
méditerranée soit l'atlantique pour
aller vers l'afrique
je pense que c'est une escale qui aura
tendance certainement à se développer
par l'avenir
et puis bordeaux offre aux paquebots un
avantage rare une escale offert de la
ville ce qui est appréciable la plupart
des forêts sans situés hors des zones
urbaines dans des endroits en général
fini
mais les responsables du tourisme de
notre région doivent imaginer proposer
de nouveaux attraits touristiques aux
organisateurs de croisières car pour
l'instant seule la traditionnelle visite
du vignoble est proposée aux
croisiéristes de passage à bordeaux
c'est insuffisant
à savoir encore la mode des croisières
vers l'amérique s'émousse au profit de
l'europe
il faut en profiter